thank you
[Music]
so today is a very special day it's all
steady day of course but we are doing
the careful boys
annual Super Bowl bet oh
should I just sit on that side with you
guys already so Joe's by himself
Joe's on an island last year was what
Chargers no it was the Rams close very
same similar colors yeah very similar
okay we'll give you that different
shades of blue salty Stadium Sofi
Stadium yeah it's a crazy statement I
know a lot about football pansy have you
been to Sophie Stadium no either way
okay it's Chiefs and the Eagles it's
Chiefs and the Eagles yep
um how are we feeling boys
I think uh from what I've heard the
Chiefs are the favorite right no they
are not they are absolutely no [__] so
the Eagles are are the favorites right
now still the Lions might move next week
you never know it always moves it always
moves I'll move those if you remember
the boys
Joe we all went in on the ramps yep and
we all won [__] money that's right
yep how much did we win again I was
close baby I think we all won like 100 I
was close 120. okay I think we turned
100 into 138 each
that's it what's the policy Joel always
bets the underdog is that what it is
against us I bet I thought I was gonna
bait against the favorite but I'll just
bet against you guys whatever whatever
we picked he goes against this yeah I
really don't want to sit here because
he's only going to catch a pack again we
know what happened yesterday what
happened yesterday
because I know you know football okay so
I mean dude it's tough right because the
Eagles are so [__] stacked like
everywhere you look they're good their
quarterback's good Jalen hurts is so
goddamn good at football their defense
is so damn good the running back miles
Sanders are so good I just look around
that team AJ my wide receiver they're
just stacked everywhere the Eagles I'm
but I think the Chiefs are gonna win
okay
about the Chiefs because I like Native
Americans that's actually a really
Progressive idea thank you yeah that's
cool did it affect anything that that
one Eagles dude got caught for like you
got arrested for Stuff
but there's a there's so there's that
guy yeah I don't know if he gets to play
or not I I don't know if it counts
against him this week but there was just
a Bengals player who got or he's getting
arrested right now for what jacking off
in public no it's like aggravated some
something uh aggravated assaulting
aggravated towards who yeah I don't know
is it good online his name's Joe Mixon
he's a very very good one and he his
lawyer came out and basically said we
believe that the charges will be dropped
so it's a big big old fat TBD whoa we'll
find out maybe you should bet for the
team that has more kids
okay I'm listening yeah because they
have a reason to fight harder it's like
a child support that's the hungry dog
runs faster that's like when uh Joe's
talking about how the Spartans and stuff
like that were like homos and games with
each other I love you so much I'm not
gonna let you die and then it's like
dude gay pride yep right because the
Spartans which this articles say which
team has more kids it doesn't escape
players yeah it really doesn't a
spreadsheet for that it's all F do you
look that up please if you guys give me
like 45 minutes I could probably figure
it out I thought a book you would know
in a second or 53 men on the roster
that's a lot so yeah who's starting
nobody knows dude
lineups that day so the Chiefs though
the Chiefs Patrick Mahomes he's a baller
widely considered the best quarterback
in the NFL and believe that honest later
than Tom Hardy or no Tom Hardy I think
he's better than Thomas
football yeah yeah
what other
I'll list all the football players I
know just here we go Joe Pesci I'm gonna
try really hard I'm actually gonna try
it yeah go ahead okay hold on hold on
Brett Favre yeah hey
[Laughter]
um
[__] knee boy what's neat Dominic
Wilkins not me boy the [__] the dude
that was honestly Colin Kaepernick Colin
Kaepernick oh right
that's what he's known for boys campaign
they call it that's true they did call
me boys
um
Chinese boys
yeah true Jeff's quarterback hasn't
played in 50 years that's almost 10.
almost 10. there's there's a young in
there
something young Steve Young yeah
Steve Young and Vincent oh and then
there's the [__] Brothers the
brothers the [__] Brothers everyone
knows that famous brothers this is one
of the major story lines of the Super
Bowl no the brother woman but the cute
white dude Brothers never mind you're
talking about the Kelsey Brothers no way
oh the other ones are really funny he's
not he's talking about the [__]
Mannings dude yes Maddie oh my God
you're talking about the meaning
that's a double what are their names
though do you not watch Eli oh Pat or no
Pat yeah true and Pat Tillman Army
Ranger you know a lot more football
players should take over all football
13.
I just see primary colors and primary
words okay he says purple primary word
we get back to the actual topic yeah
right so okay how much are we how much
are we laying down and where do we want
to put our money and does anybody have a
tingle does anybody have a little tingle
of a feeling
my reasons of American love okay but
then the eagle is also Native American
too Eagles are also kind of like you
know
okay so if the Eagles win isn't there
the whole like uh storyline that when
Eagles win the [__] Super Bowl
they're gonna tear down the whole city
yeah they're gonna Burn the City to the
ground notorious like celebrities they
always keep saying that or that's what
they're known for oh that's what they're
known for they level the city today
Cinder it's great wow they're gonna
destroy the Liberty Bell bro the closer
they get to winning the the more
grandmas start crying and locking all
their windows and doors
which ones have the hotter cheerleaders
um in my in my opinion
the Cowboys no but then between oh right
right right right okay okay
um Cowboy is cheerleader is pretty hot
actually yeah yeah it's cheap it's not a
whole cheerleader Squad look like
Pocahontas oh that'd be so cool yes they
do they dress up in traditional bars
again yeah they're the there's the
jiggliest bunch in the NFL I bet they
were yeah they really had to wear dude
watch out jiggly yeah wow why do you
think it's bad he's five
no that's true that's perfect for five
dollars that's his favorite kind of
jello the jiggly one yeah yeah what what
um does it has anybody heard anything
about the teams at all you guys got an
inside track you guys got any sharps in
your life any any sports uh Bettors well
you told me that guy's injured
Patrick Mahomes does have a high school
so he's the inside yeah I'm the shark
you're our Insider in this room on the
shop because you guys are smooth brains
well yeah we don't know anything about
football where are they playing this
year I know a little bit about MMA stuff
but then I've also been tuning out for a
little bit too okay that's fair so we're
playing in Arizona Arizona
oh that's where the Super Bowl is that's
what the Super Bowl is it's also where
um there's been there's been many Super
Bowls before
so it's 57.
we bet 100 last year and we won like
138. we should just bet like 138. we
should bump on it yeah pull it right
back in so does that mean I bet negative
you should always double down whatever
how much did I bet you should do
Martingale that's the same amount as us
didn't you I maybe you have that more
you got to go big dude you got to go
Martin Gillman so you bet 136 I bet uh
300 or what you bet 100 I think I don't
want to spend that kind of money on this
kind of game You're Gonna Go Martingale
method you have what kind of games
that's where that's where if you lose
the bet if you put down like 100 bucks
say and if you lose you double it down
the next time and then you double it
down the next time you double down oh
yeah so he has to bet what 200 then yeah
my odds would be better if it if I'm
always betting Underdog but then I have
to bet against you guys each time that
means my odds might be worse but but we
might well we did we did the um the
favorite last year the Rams were heavy
too yeah I suppose I think our favorite
this year Eagles are definitely favorite
yeah so same [__] so you are betting the
underdog this time oh I didn't know you
guys are gonna BET The Eagles I don't
know yet oh see what's your Eagle so I
say Eagles I'm leaning towards Eagles
but I but I just think my homes is so
[__] good he could play on one leg
how long do I got injured but he was
injured last week and he balled up how
many TVs did he throw last week
I don't remember off top of my head I
think it's three
who they play against the Bengals it was
the Bengals yeah and it was a close game
it was a really oh no it was yeah it was
two touchdowns Bengals almost won you
said Patrick Mahomes I'm gonna look at
his Instagram see if he's distracted by
the way his brother people don't like
his brother no one likes his brother or
his lady right his brother's little Tick
Tock guy does all this all this kind of
[__] you know he dances
get up and do it it's better for the
algorithm yeah yeah it's better yeah so
he's going I'm just reenacting right so
he goes like this and [__] let's do it
with fervor oh wow somebody's been
practicing or are you jacking off two
dicks I'm jacking off two dicks I think
Patrick might win you think so he's
locked in look how focused he is only
football posts
that's Focus man let's let's check out
the other guy Jalen hurt Dylan hurts
yeah stay good
or something it's he's distracted what
do you think you're gonna find just like
strippers on this next guy's page or
what he could be his food or some [__]
stuff that's football unreleased food
how do you spell Jalen
j-a-l-e-n-j-a-l-e-n I bet you Tom Brady
has food picks or he's kissing his
[__] kid dude yeah he's kissing a kid
probably Tom Brady he's officially
retiring yeah he's officially retired uh
you know what so Jalen is kind of
focused too but he got some swag shots
so I think he's kind of distracted he
likes cars and [__] so he might he might
be getting this like he got his little
swag shots the only kind of analysis you
can get Patrick Mahomes is [__] he
was locked in you could tell the whole
grid nine by uh three by three was all
football stuff this guy is [__]
promoting backpacks and [__] nah I don't
think so dude Patrick Mahal's been
playing a lot of golf though you better
watch out I'm not posting it so it never
happened well a lot of people
um because Andy Reed is the coach of the
Chiefs a lot of people believe that the
Chiefs might have the edge because of
that so Nick siriani is the the Eagles
coach and he's kind of a he's a he's a
newer coach compared to Andy Reid who's
kind of a legend and what's one of the
interesting story lines is Andy Reed
used to coach the Eagles so maybe
there's like a little bit of oh I want
to [__] get him because they fired
him so he look at this and when's the
last time the Eagles have been through
Pelosi's page see how Focus she is with
politics so you know she you know she's
dialed the [__] dialed in yeah that's
what she's making those tricks no
Heavies exposed anywhere I didn't know
Nazi police yeah Instagram that is
interesting
Joe always being the underdog though
because it's he gets to win more if he's
actually
always bet favorite right do you ever
like feel lonely and like slightly
regretted though no like not being with
your friends if I win it's pretty cool
yeah but you lost last time do you feel
like lonely and like no because I almost
won and I almost almost had a in your
face moment almost one I guess that's
worth it maybe we but I'm trying to get
a 50 chance every time I have a weird
feeling about this though because I look
I I'll be honest I was hot last year I
couldn't [__] lose
right I was so dialed in like board
saying I could just see the game I could
like see through the game and see into
the Matrix of the game and I knew the
[__] Rams were gonna win I knew
then what do you see about this year
then even my second quarter though but
now the forces are you're still upset
really like I was so dialed into the
game I was like I was controlling the
game right I had my eyes closed and I
was [__] controlling the game right
so then fast forward a little bit I make
my next bet I actually bet 138 on the
Warriors to win game five and they do
I'm dialed in I'm literally controlling
the world right so then we fast forward
to the NFL season I start betting during
the playoffs and I have not won a single
[__] bet the entire playoff run it's
been like three and a half weeks of
losing how did you lose control of the
world Austin I don't know I don't know I
think I'm not focused I think Rick
Bart's saying I'm like looking at
cheerleaders butts and stuff I'm not
thinking about the games
he was focused on his thing that's what
I'm saying did you pick the Niners to
win over I did and I picked the Bengals
to win and I did a parlay because I was
so confident I was like why were you so
confident like because Joe burrow is a
[__] baller and I thought that
everyone was [__] talking the Niners so
much it was kind of wild like I was like
you guys were disrespecting a really
good football team but then Brock pretty
goes down immediate his elbow dude as
soon as the game began then I just sit
there with my [__] dick out like
can't believe this shit's happening
today why was your dick out
well I mean it's like it's like you know
flaccidly just hanging there all lots of
leaves yeah awful awful so yeah I maybe
don't trust me because I feel like the
Chiefs might win and maybe we should go
the other way because I have been I've
been whiff enough that's interesting I
like the idea of uh trying to kill your
slump yeah so you think the chief's
gonna win that's why you're gonna vote
for no I think the Eagles are gonna win
that's why I think maybe I go Chiefs
statistically it means I have to bet for
them you can't do this dude but you know
statistically you know that table if
it's like black black black
the more blacks there are the higher the
likelihood is supposed to hit red next
so what if it's that what if you've been
losing losing losing losing losing it's
lost 8 500 yeah
but isn't it don't you think there's
something to the fact that like the
Chiefs recently kind of been in the
Super Bowl what like two years ago yeah
but they lost right do you think that
helps them like be in the like the arena
and like deal with all the hype unlike
the Eagles because they haven't been
there in a while right and they're
pretty new they're pretty 2017 they won
they won the whole [__] thing the
same team where there's new Eagles new
members some some of the old teams some
are still there barely right they want
they won 2017. and yeah they have to
they're still rebuilding there's a
statue outside of their building from
that win because you know the Eagles
were [__] nuts obviously and like
they've made a statue of Nick Foles
who's like a backup quarterback but he
did really good that balled out but he's
the backup quarterback statue outside
that's how [__] the nuts Eagles fans
are wow
dude is there not much going on out
there he's got like an eagle on his
necklace right now maybe we should
follow the signs
they're hardcore though like remember
Bradley Cooper He's a big tiny needles
fan remember that movie Silver Lining
yes
that's like all about how Eagles fans
are nuts basically or Invincible oh
that's why you sock someone like they're
in that bonfire scene or whatever the
tailgate scene oh that makes sense now
we don't have that kind of sport
Spectrum we don't have that kind of
sport enthusiasm in L.A [__] no no we
won the Super Bowl
enough nah
when Korea and Mexico like they were
both waving out their Flags going crazy
I saw more of that City Pride or state
no City because Bay Area does yo you see
Argentina's [__] partying though no
after the World Cup yes it was insane
that that's what we need to do you know
what I mean like the whole country comes
out the road was like hacked the whole
country flew I drone over you can't see
like a sewer manhole like you there's
everybody's everywhere I haven't seen
that since the Lakers three-peat oh yeah
I feel like the Lakers culture is
probably the deepest roots that we have
as a city yeah but like LA Rams are
still like so new kind of new right I
don't trust you as new as a stadium when
the Lakers repeat it I remember exactly
where I was because there were cars
being flipped the first time or the
second time this is the second well you
said three oh the second three people
yeah I was I was going to grad night
dude wow yeah oh [__] that's hilarious
dude you're so young I always forget how
about Vegas would you be betting are you
a little young
should you be betting I can't even rent
a car we gotta [__] place
no no I don't see any uh pride in Vegas
there's no Pride wow nice Pride nights
golden knights how about WNBA Aces
exactly last year we got first pick
right we got to pick who we wanted no
how about am I always betting Underdog
or am I betting against you guys every
single time why don't we bet against him
this time
I like that Progressive yeah yeah I
don't even know I don't even know well
he knows and he still doesn't know yeah
sucking ass look let's just well I chose
the Chiefs because I I just like [__] we
gotta take the Eagles
[Music]
it's the Eagles but like this 139 bucks
138 bucks I'm putting 200 on the Chiefs
let's do it
all right wait um
right now
you're on camera all right let me right
now we're bambooing camera and don't get
distracted by Nancy Pelosi and then I'm
gonna cross and I'm gonna cross state
lines and make the bet for us should I
and should we ask people in the Discord
be like hey venmos if you want to
[__] uh
we'll pay you out we swear to God we'll
pay you out
which one is it which one is it Steve
Green Oh Graphics none of that's me wait
maybe the first one one is it just at
Steve Green
that's me yeah sick light yeah that's me
I hate you yeah you baby you're gonna
put a underdog bat for me oh man yeah of
course hey look at this the last time I
paid stuff are better right it says
reimbursement for Shiva Inu coin
consultation in which you said go all in
did I pay the right Steve for the
favorite though all right Steve yeah
Bart pay me okay Eagles are the favorite
okay currently the lines could move Fly
Eagles Fly because my default is always
bet Underdog I like the Thunder 138 dogs
are better I tried it last year it
[__] sucked all right Steve did you
get it I got it Anthony Eagles I'm
either all right let's go Eagles